this morning Indonesian authorities are
desperately working to get food and
other aid to victims of the devastating
earthquake and tsunami drone video
reveals the widespread destruction from
Friday's twin natural disasters the
death toll has risen to more than 1,200
people that number is expected to climb
more than 60,000 people are displaced
from their homes Ben Tracy is in the
hard-hit town of Pulu where rescuers are
digging through the mud and rubble
searching for survivors the situation
here in Palo is desperate there's very
little water electricity or gas the town
is resorting to building a mass grave
for the bodies they're finding and now
people are flocking to the airport
trying to find a way out when we arrived
in Pulu this morning this is what we saw
thousands of people camped out on the
airport tarmac they are hoping one of
these cargo planes will deliver them
from the health that is now their home
are you gonna be able to get on a plane
today and leave here yes absolutely we
got absolutely be light blue and then
thankful to God this woman has been
waiting outside with her eight month old
girl for three days now how is your
daughter doing while we were talking the
ground started shaking so that's an
earthquake stay away from that are you
okay
yeah you don't want to be under don't be
under there as you can imagine if you've
gone through what these people have gone
through this is just frightening to have
the ground shake again especially when
you're sitting under this for shade out
here in the 90 degree game it's been
four days since the earth here violently
shook a massive 7.5 magnitude quake that
triggered a tsunami heavy machinery has
finally arrived to aid the rescue effort
but it's now increasingly a grim
recovery operation in this part of town
the earthquake shook the ground so
violently that it basically turned it
into quicksand and that swallowed
everything that was on top of it and now
in all of this rubble you see here
rescue workers tell us they think up to
70 bodies are buried there are still
signs of hope on Monday night a 38 year
old man was pulled from the rubble of a
building alive he was able to talk to
the rescuers who spent 3 hours to save
him sadly that kind of story is now rare
today one of the rescue workers showed
me this big piece of white paper that
they had up against a wall where they
write down the victims they have found
and today in just their small search
area they found seven more bodies for
CBS this morning Ben Tracy
Pulu Indonesia then Tracy in Indonesia
thank you